-Welcome back, everybody.
I'm here with some
very special guests.
They just made history
as the first all-female group
from South Korea
to land on Billboard's
on-demand streaming songs chart
with their hit song
"Sour Candy," with Lady Gaga.
Here is Jisoo, Lisa, Jennie, and
Rosé from BLACKPINK.
-Hi!
We're BLACKPINK.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
We are big fans.
You guys are awesome
for doing this.
Let me give some quick stats
about you guys.
You have had five
number-one singles
on the Billboard
world digital songs chart.
You're the most followed
girl group on Spotify
with over 21 million followers.
You are the most subscribed
music group on YouTube
with 37.3 million subscribers.
That is unbelievable.
And on Instagram,
you have 24.4 million followers.
That's major.
Do you understand
how big that is?
-We literally don't.
It's like --
It makes us freeze
every time we hear this.
It's -- We just thank our fans
so much for the love,
because, you know...
It's too much.
-Your first studio album
is coming out,
and I am all about it.
Tonight, you are debuting
the first single off that album,
called "How You Like That?"
But before we get to that,
since you're here,
I want to play a game with you
that is called the
Try Not to Laugh Challenge.
Here we go.
-Try not to laugh.
-Whatever you do,
please, try not to laugh.
-The game is very simple.
I'm gonna show you
some funny videos,
and you have to try
to not laugh
while watching them.
If you can make it all the way
through without laughing,
you're gonna win that round.
-Okay. Let's do it.
-All right. Here we go.
Our first video.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
[ Kids screaming ]
-His teeth!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Dings ]
-Okay.
-Oh, no!
-Who laughed first?
-I think she did.
-She started
before the video started.
-Jisoo, you laughed before
the video even started playing.
-Yeah.
-She thought the screenshot
was just too funny to handle.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
Here we go.
Video number two.
-Okay. We're ready.
-Oh, don't.
[ Dog barking melodically ]
[ Buzzer ]
-This has to be a voiceover.
-That was hard for me
'cause I've actually
seen that video before
on Instagram.
-Okay.
-But I think that is adorable.
I love that.
-It's a very close game so far.
Here we go.
Video number three.
-Okay.
-Jimmy Fallon.
[ Triumphant music plays ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Dings ]
-Okay. I'm --
I'm not good at this game.
I'm just gonna say that.
She didn't laugh.
She won this.
-Thank you
for not laughing at my face.
I appreciate that.
[ Laughter ]
-No! Like, the fact
that your face is --
-Seriously.
-You know, too excited.
-You can't do that to Jimmy.
We love Jimmy.
-For this last video, guys,
I'm not kidding.
Whoever does not laugh
gets the bonus point round
of 10,000 points
and will be the champion.
-Okay.
-Oh.
-I'm gonna win this.
-Oh, no.
-Here we go.
The last video.
-Ooh.
Ooh!
Aah!
Aah! Aah!
Oh [bleep]
[ Buzzer ]
-One minute!
Okay.
Ain't no more, ain't no more.
Okay, get the window!
Yo, let --
[ Buzzer ]
[ Dings ]
[ Laughter ]
-I think we have a winner.
-Oh!
She won!
-Takes the win!
BLACKPINK,
we love you guys so much.
Congrats on the record.
-Thank you so much for having us
on your show, Jimmy.
-Congratulations.
Thanks for playing.
Bye!
We love you guys.
-Bye!
See you soon! Bye!